[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm Brian
Dorsey from Google Developer
Relations.
And this is Eric Johnson--
ERIC JOHNSON: Hi.
BRIAN DORSEY:
--also from Google.
And we have with us today
from SaltStack Joseph Hall.
JOSEPH HALL: Hey, guys.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
we're going to talk
about how SaltStack
and Google Compute
Engine work very
smoothly together.
So Compute Engine itself
is virtual machines
hosted on Google's
infrastructure.
It's disk, network, and
the virtual machines.
And what's SaltStack?
JOSEPH HALL: SaltStack is
a configuration management
and automation framework.
And it's designed for
ease of use and speed.
And it's geared especially for
massive scale and flexibility.
BRIAN DORSEY: Massive
scale is a good fit.
Let's go straight to the demo.
ERIC JOHNSON: Absolutely, OK, so
for the demo today, what we're
going to do is use Salt to
spin up four Compute Engine
instances and configure
them as Salt minions.
We'll install Apache and a
custom index dot HTML page.
We'll open up port 80 to
allow HTTP traffic in.
We'll set up a Compute
Engine load balancer.
And then we'll demo
that out, make sure
that everything's
working correctly.
So if you're interested
in wanting to repeat this,
we have a Get Help
repository set up.
And I'll show you links
at the end of this.
But this goes through all
of the details on what we
did to get this demo
set up, including
all of the configuration that
you would need to have set up.
But what we'll do for
the purposes of this
is we'll just skip
right down to Demo Time.
And the first
command I'll show you
is how we can use
Salt Cloud, which
is a utility baked into
Salt, to go ahead and create
four Compute Engine instances.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about Compute Engine.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome,
OK, so, like I said,
this is virtual machines
on Google's network
infrastructure,
Google's infrastructure
all the way through.
And the whole system
is designed to be fast.
And this is fast and consistent.
So we've got instances
booting right now.
In fact, they just booted.
So that was four instances that
allocated new block storage
devices, copied
over the boot image
to those-- the latest image--
actually booted from them
and handed off to a script
to run whatever software
you want to run.
And in this case, that is Salt.
So, Joseph, what's
going on here?
JOSEPH HALL: So
once the Salt Cloud
determines that the
machine is up and running
and ready to be connected to,
then it's going to log in.
And it's going to upload this
bootstrap script for Salt.
That's going to
detect the operating
system that it's running on.
It's going to configure the
repositories for that OS,
and download and install Salt,
and get it up and running,
and get all the keys
accepted and ready to go
so that we can start
throwing Salt Cloud
commands at the instance.
And since Salt itself is
an automation framework
and remote execution
engine, then
we can throw commands at it
to figure which packages need
to be installed, to find which
files need to be laid down
in the system and what they
need to look like, and also
throw remote execution
commands at it
and have it perform just our
regular tasks that we perform
on a regular basis.
BRIAN DORSEY: Nice.
ERIC JOHNSON: Yeah, so I think
it looks like we're probably
just waiting here for the
last couple ones to finish.
And there they come in.
So what we should end
up seeing is a list
of attributes for each
of these instances
once it goes ahead and displays.
And sure enough, there's the
JSON output for each of these.
So what we're going
to want to do next
is show you a little bit
about Salt's remote execution.
And we'll use this
command over here.
And what I'll do
is paste that in.
And what this is going to do
is it's going to use Salt.
And the asterisk there means
to match all of the minions.
And it's going to execute a
command with the command dot
run module, or the
command module.
And it's just going to
execute the uname-a function
across each those
or the command,
and then automatically
return those results back.
So you can see it executed
all those in parallel.
We didn't have to wait for
each one of those to complete.
We got all of the data back.
So that verifies that everything
was provisioned correctly.
The minion is listening for
commands from the master.
So the next thing I
want to do is go ahead
and use the high state command.
And what this is going to
do since I have this already
configured ahead of time--
what those configuration files
I have set up
ahead of time, it's
going to go ahead
and install Apache
on each of these
instances, and then
lay down a custom
index dot HTML file.
The index dot HTML
file that we lay down
is going to have the host name
of that instance baked into it.
The next thing I
want to do is I just
want to make sure
that since I'm going
to be doing this is a web
server-- so I want to make sure
that port 80 traffic is allowed.
So we'll go ahead and use the
Salt Cloud utility to configure
Compute Engine's
networking firewall
rules to allow TCP colon 80.
And it looks like that command
is completed successfully.
And the next thing I want to
do is use Salt Cloud again
to configure Compute
Engine's load balancer.
Let me just paste that in there.
And then hopefully
Brian can tell us
a little bit about
load balancing.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes,
this load balancer
were configuring
right now is actually
a Google data center
level load balancer.
So if you're
interested in more this
is a very powerful
load balancer.
It's aware of the health of the
instances as they come and go.
And we published a
blog post recently
where we documented
testing this out
to 1 million queries per second
without any pre-warming at all.
So it's really powerful.
ERIC JOHNSON: Great,
and so we've already got
it configured.
And one of the attributes
that comes back from here
is the public IP address
for this load balancer.
And so it's a single IP address.
Now, in this case, I
only have four instances,
but let's say I have
200 instances behind.
I can still send all my traffic
just to that single IP address.
So let's go ahead
and see what happens.
If things worked correctly what
we should be able to do here
is see the web page for each
of our instances served up
through our load balancer.
So it should--
BRIAN DORSEY: Nice, as the
color-- oh, just changed.
ERIC JOHNSON: Yeah, so
hopefully, we've seen what?
One and three.
There's four and two.
So it looks like
all four of them
are provisioned, being
successfully behind the load
balancer.
And we did all of
that with Salt.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
ERIC JOHNSON: Here's some
links for more information.
So as I said, there's
a Get Help repository
if you want to replicate
all of this on your own
as well as a link over there
to the documentation that
shows all of the functionality
that is available to you
for Compute Engine from
Salt, and more information
about the Google Cloud
Platform and SaltStack.
And I'd like to say a
very special thank you
for Joseph Hall for joining
us today to talk about this.
JOSEPH HALL: Thanks, guys.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
thank you for watching.